okay okay okay okay I get it I watch the
wrong video I should have watched the
gameplay as well and not just the
announcement trailer I'm sorry
hey what's up guys my name is Ayana
welcome to another reaction slash review
video today we're gonna be taking a look
at rationale a craft applaud again but
this time I'm gonna be looking at the
gameplay because that's what I failed to
obviously look at last time and I'm
sorry for that I also want to mention
quickly that when I looked at the
announcement trailer which I'll have
links up there a few people did correct
me and point out that Clank is in fact
right right and of course I had no idea
that the developers said that and that
was the case because that was all the
footage that I saw and I guess I just
didn't look closely enough on the frame
to actually see all of the reflection so
thank you to all those for correcting me
and pointing that out I will be
definitely paying attention to the fact
that he is right raised here I mean I
would honestly expect him to be right
raised because the fact that Clank is
just like a full kind of metal body it's
a very good candidate to show off the
right tracing and I feel like it you
know I mean you would want to show it
off if you had the power to actually do
that but anyway I'm excited to take a
look at the actual gameplay for rational
flank the video that I'll be watching I
think is from IGN I couldn't really find
exactly the best source to find this I
know that the full livestream did did
show a little bit of this as well as
some developers talking about that but I
thought that this was the best I could
find as a two-minute 14 second only know
what to expect but I'm excited to dive
in link in the description below as
always let's take a look at the gameplay
demo for ration and clank rift apart and
where are my headphones
okay this just completely dives into it
I don't even know what's going on I
think what I'll do for this video is
I'll have a more general just watch of
it just to kind of take it in and see
what's going on and then I'll kind of
try and provide a little bit more
comment as to what I'm thinking okay so
before we dive into the next story for
it we'll already watch like half the
trailer I want to take a look or the
half of the gameplay demo sorry I want
to have a look a little bit more closely
at some of what I'm seeing here so the
scene itself is fairly standard I'm not
seeing anything here that is like you
know an overwhelming amount of detail or
just something that wouldn't have been
possible with last gen because it's it's
all it's all fairly standard now the
things that I have noticed straight away
and of course this is kind of like a
reaction as well as a review so this is
just basically just my initial thoughts
and things that stick out to me the most
but one thing that I did notice was
during this scene the floor the floor is
reflecting quite a lot and it's a little
bit hard to see because I guess this is
taken from the live stream and you can
see in this frame for example the
quality is not very good but there's
this constant reflection going on here
now that makes me think that it is a ray
traced reflection
it does look dynamic in a few of the
scenes that I saw so like for example I
think over here when he rotates there's
like the screen is actually moving here
and you can actually see that
you can obviously see all of these
characters here and the fact that they
are in fact being reflected in the floor
the door as well in fact that the door
is moving is kind of being reflected
here that's kind of it's clearly a
raytrace reflection if you look back
back to these shots the fact that we
have a reflection here technically
speaking it it doesn't have to be right
trace I'm sure it is in this case
because they are using ray tracing I'm
just saying that this kind of reflection
of the outside environment could easily
just be a cube map that the shader is
just looking up every time it needs to
render something here it's fairly
standard and pretty easy to do that
especially with this level of blur
because blurring and blurry reflections
are generally a lot more performance
intensive to do then crystal clear sharp
reflections and then this is a really
good example of the bright Ray's
reflections where you see like this
octopus all of these kind of tentacles
being reflected perfectly here it's also
worth noting that the reflection
resolution does seem quite high I mean
it is blurry but that's to be expected
because the surface is a little bit
rough and not really like a mirror at
all which to me always looks more
impressive than if it was a
crystal-clear reflection
okay and then we're diving into another
world here if you people point it out
that they think that these worlds here
are actually real real life running kind
of dynamic worlds and not just images
and I mean I haven't seen anything yet
that suggests that that's true I just
like from a developer point of view I
just don't see the reason why you would
have a real kind of you know separate
scenes actually running and being
rendered just to render them on these
pieces if this is all you're showing it
just seems very overkill I'm almost I'm
almost a hundred percent sure that this
is just either a static texture or maybe
it is some kind of like animation or
baked kind of moving changing texture
but I don't think that this is actually
being rendered in real time I just feel
like that would be that would be
essentially a waste of resources not to
mention that you would have to keep the
data for all of these scenes kind of in
memory so that you could actually do
that it just doesn't seem like it's
worth it
[Music]
there's that kind of depth of field blur
as well I really like that it looks
pretty good yeah I mean there's a lot of
particles I'm saying like these smoke
effects just general glowing particles
that are the same because why not but in
general the only thing I really see here
as being deterministically next-gen is
the whole kind of ray tracing usage
right so ray trace reflections are
probably the biggest thing I see with
the shadows especially at this quality
of this live stream it's very difficult
to see if they're using ray traced
shadows or ray traced an occlusion for
example I just don't I can't really tell
because the resolution isn't really that
high there's a little bit of a warping
effect here if I go back a few frames
there it is that kind of warping effect
that's very cool as well I'm a fan of
that some water effects
the grass looks quite nice and it even
looks like there's almost like a
tilt-shift effect here because the edges
of this grass look blurry and I'm not
sure I think that's just a particle but
it it could be even chromatic aberration
so that might be simulating like some
kind of real wealth camera effects which
I guess is cool not sure why people
necessarily like adding imperfections
all the time but I guess just to make it
seem more real but anyway so we have
this kind of side blurriness here in
general and obviously that's not really
due to the depth because they're on the
same kind of depth plane as the rest of
the grass here but those effects are
kind of cool it's kind of just like a
subtle post-process effect that just
focuses your attention more on what's
going on which is very subtle and
sometimes hard to actually see but when
you take a look at it it's it's the
reason why a lot of these games feel
like you're really like either it's
immersive or that you actually
understand what's going on specifically
at your focal point even though there's
just so much stuff going on in the scene
in general
that's cool
I mean I don't know where he went - you
must you mean that's not yeah here's
this little teleport so many particles I
hate the fact that they've got a youtube
end screen right here I mean I guess the
science fold classic
okay and that's the gameplay trailer
that's like all of it I'm gonna go over
it a little bit more and see if there's
anything else that I pick up and I want
to say okay so I've had a little bit
more of a look at it and basically this
is what I have to say I think that it
looks great it's very hard to tell
certain really specific kind of finicky
graphics things like whether or not that
shadows are like raytrace and how smooth
they are and how soft they are and how
the ambient occlusion looks and all that
stuff because of the fact that it is
live streamed and it looks a little bit
blocky like you can see here however I
think that the three biggest things here
are the few biggest things that actually
separates this from from what would
probably have been achievable in last
gen it's probably just the effects and I
don't just mean effects as in the the
particles or things like that I just
mean generally if you take the frame at
its core and you look at it at it in
terms of just the geometry and the
textures to me like it does look quite
detailed but because the aesthetic is
more or less a bit simplistic
deliberately and it's not trying to be
like you know really really detailed of
texturing that in itself doesn't stick
out as something that wouldn't have been
achievable with the previous generation
because even if these textures might be
like 2 times the resolution it's not
something that's going to be a hundred
percent of parent when you just look at
look at the frame I'm sure the frame
itself is being rounded at a higher
resolution just because they have the
power to do that but ultimately if you
get what I mean it's not that big of a
jump the things that they've actually
done that probably wouldn't have been
achievable in the previous generation at
least to this extent are all of the
effects so for example the particle
effects they have a lot of particles
that's probably something that they're
able to do that they would not just have
had the opportunity to add in that many
particles in the previous generation
also the rate all the ray-tracing
affects is they're able to do so for
example the ray tracing the ray trace
reflections they might be using ray
traced shadows or through looking at
ratchet here not really a good example
but it that almost looks like just a
normal like shadow map with some
softness and some filtering going on so
it
they might not even be using Rachel's
shadows but rachel is reflections
they've confirmed they are using so I
can see that obviously those scenes with
the reflections look pretty good and it
was obvious that they weren't screen
space reflections just because they were
reflecting a large a large kind of
amount of the actual environment that
wouldn't have been possible if you're
just using like all the kind of
reflection techniques that aren't as
good and then finally the depth of field
and the blurriness like this kind of
tilt shift blur effects that stuff looks
super high quality if we look at like
scenes like this where we have quite a
nice blur and yeah this quality really
isn't helping but we have quite a nice
blur that I saw in the previous video
with the announcement trailer and also
kind of different tiers of blur and it
looks buttery smooth and we've got the
whole tilt shift effect all of that
stuff together requires quite a bit of
processing power that probably wouldn't
have been possible to do to this degree
of quality with the previous generation
so particle effects post-processing
effects like all this depth of field and
tilt shift effect and blurriness and
obviously array tracing as well that's
the biggest thing that I see in terms of
them being able to have more objects on
screen or a slightly higher poly count
or things like that that's that's not as
apparent has all of this stuff in my
opinion like this in it especially look
how many particles there are it looks
great anyway hope you guys enjoyed this
little reaction slash review of the
Russian Clank groove depart gameplay
demo let me know what your thoughts are
about this game are you excited for it
do you think this is a good kind of show
off of the PlayStation fives new
technology what things in this
particular gameplay demo stick out to
you as being impressive compared to the
last generation because I must confess
even though I've been talking a lot
about that I haven't even seen rationing
clanks previous generation games I'm not
really sure so my thoughts are basically
based on what I know about the previous
generation in general not specifically
the Ratchet and Clank games what games
are you most excited about in this next
generation of consoles which do you
think are the most impressive and what
do you want me to check out next I know
a few people have been suggesting that I
take a look at the new horizon game and
I'd love to do that but I also wouldn't
mind taking a look at some Xbox games
because I know that a few people are
beginning to think that I'm being paid
by Sony which is completely not true at
all I'm just looking at what I'm seeing
and just just giving my thoughts on it
anyway I hope you guys enjoyed this
video please don't forget to hit the
like button
if you did because it really helps the
channel out thank you all for watching I
will see you next time have a great day
goodbye
[Music]
you